école des parents un petit américium un
gène siècle qui est le premier en nette
progression
l'idée bout limites matérielles aux
mines il fait l'expérience de
concessions dit
imaginons que je sois à la limite que je
me positionne mal à nous de la faire des
étoiles fixes
est ce que je peux pour nous rendre un
bâton de la main au delà c'est absurde
que j'ai pensé que je le vois je te
faire
et s'il ya toujours un nouvel espace
vers lequel tendre la main le ballon
c'est un petit kit les relents et
l'extension sans doute puisque c'est
donc ainsi le concept d'un fini à partir
d'une réflexion solide et par la même
occasion ils donnent une magnifique
définition du travail de chercheur qui
revient exactement à se positionner aux
mythes et attendre battre au delà la
recherche consiste à repousser les
limites de la connaissance et pour se
faire dépasser les limites conceptuelles
et technologique
alors pour ma part que le travail à la
limite de l'infiniment petit en physique
des particules
dans ce domaine de recherche
fondamentale on peut dépasser les
limites de plusieurs façons ça peut être
franchir un obstacle
par exemple c'est grâce à un physique
expérimentale pour expérimenter paris ça
peut être franchir un des technologies
mais ça peut être aussi regarder les
choses si un angle légèrement différent
et là c'est souvent le cas en physique
théorique
alors je vais illustrer ses amis c'est
avec la maison et celui de la recherche
de la partie plus piratés
2 qui a été découverte au grand
collisionneur de hadrons le lhc en 2010
vos textes suivants la physique des
particules c'est-à-dire l'étude de
l'univers bout de ses constituants
élémentaires et une discipline assez
jeune avec une centaine d'années est
assez construite par aller-retour entre
les développements théoriques et les
développements astéries bouton elles
composent aujourd'hui sur un modèle le
modèle standard de la physique des
particules qui vécut dans une seule et
mirifique équation tout le contenu et la
dynamique de l'univers
au niveau des constructions alimentaire
lors d'un point de vue théorique cette
population avec un câble
elle répond à tous les possibles connais
la physique le fil y compris les
symétries fondamentales de l'univers et
d'un point de vue expérimental elle est
validée ça veut dire que toutes les
valeurs de paramètres que l'on veut
calculées à partir de cette équation
correspondent et avec trois mois une
précision redoutable aux observations
mental alors combien comprend le lien
entre expérience et théorie il faut bien
se dire que chaque cercle cette équation
correspond soit une particule la
profanation d'un véhicule soit
l'interaction particules d'entre elles
il ya trois catégories de particules
dans le modèle standard de la physique
des particules
il ya d'ailleurs les particules de
matière qu'on appelle aussi les derniers
que vous voyez ici dans ce tableau alors
on a tous connu les lectoure en bas mais
ses cousins aussi le mot et aux
territoires du train de l'est si ward
dont lui et le dé qui constitue
majoritairement le retourne donc l'a12
constituants élémentaires en matière ces
particules interagissent entre elles
en échangeant un autre type de particule
pour m'appelle celle ci les beaux jours
et heures et qui correspond aux
interactions
alors il ya le photon à paris tout à
l'heure pour l'interaction
électromagnétique et de manière
similaire
y aller plus loin pour l'interaction
forte qui a les responsables de la cause
du nucléaire
et puis les w les aides pour
l'interaction peng qui elle est
responsable par exemple de la
désintégration nucléaire pétain et puis
tout seul dans sa catégorie
le boson de higgs est un beauceron
cameron alors ce modèle comme je lé dinh
a beaucoup évolué au cours du temps et
au début des années 60 qu'il était l'un
des câbles très satisfaisant par stoke
extraordinairement prédictif avec un
régis problème c'est que l'équation pour
respecter les symétries fondamentales de
l'univers
un conseil que les masses des particules
soit strictement mule
or ça s'est construit par l'expérience
en particulier par les bosons w z
d'avertir il a fallu le génie de ces
trois messieurs mais ce est ouverte
ids et brutt et de bien d'autres encore
pour résoudre franchir cette
en regardant les choses ils ont proposé
ce qu'on appelle une brisure de symétrie
douce douce compagne alors il suffit
pour ça de rajouter dans les passes ont
un potentiel que je vous présente ici et
qui pour une raison évidente est un peu
les potentiels ranch à prometic ce corps
entière et bien sûr symétrique de
rotation de fournes axe vertical qui
passe par son ensemble
si les particules dans ce conte ancien à
cet endroit là j'assimile infini qui
décrivent tous la même si l'édile sauf
que ça serve état métastable parce que
la nature prévert les états de plus
basse énergie
quant à particules va tomber dans le
potentiel par exemple à cet endroit là
là apparemment la physique décrit par
terre du sa symétrie que la particule
elle a choisi un endroit particulier du
format crevette
mais les pratiques en revanche elle a
toujours gardé sa symétrie et en gros
c'est ça qu'on appelle une rizière de
symétrie douce ou spontanées ses gardes
et symétriques les équations sous
jacente de la physique les permettre aux
états physiques de briser ces symétrie
de ne pas respecter
fondamentales de l'univers et c'est
grâce à ce type de mécanisme que les
théoriciens comptons prendre en compte
dans l'équation
les masses des particules tout en
respectant les symétries fondamentales
de l'univers
alors pour pouvoir valider la nouvelle
technique avec vrai bon on le lui dit
non il fallait évidemment observé celui
là plus parler particulièrement vers
sont instables
ça veut dire que si tu crées sitôt
désintégrer en d'autres particules est
normal quand tu le dis si tôt je n'aime
pas dans quelques rides c'est de l'ordre
de 10 - 23 secondes
c'est à dire si jaune paille en écrivant
pour vous 0,5 milliard $ milliards 2 0
une prime pour observer et étudier ces
particules installe et bien dans les
produits pour les regarder un élan c'est
ce qu'on appelle une collision
producteurs de particules et de protons
à la prière
où l acheter uniquement en vertu de la
célèbre formule d'einstein e mc2 avec
eux pour l'énergie égale même classe et
de l'a13 de la lumière au carré et peut
à partir de l'énergie masse d'énergie
cinétique des particules qui entrent en
collision
créer de la main de nouvelles
particulières évidemment plus on
accélère une particule qui m'enchante
volition puis on l'a d'énergie
disponible pour ré des particules
massives et pour la théorie ne prédit
pas la base d'articles de recherche
comme c'est carole bolide est pas pour
maximiser les chances de l'observer on
reproduit démolition à la plus haute
énergie possible
ça c'est une chose mais d'autres bras on
a déjà joué un peu plus tôt dans la
soirée la mécanique quantique est
gouverné par des probables qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que dans une
vision à la chaîne je ne sais pas à
l'avancé quelle partie du même produit
en revanche je sais calculé avec elle
pour la vérité quelle fréquence telle ou
telle partie plus m
et à vous accueillir au maire reconduit
en moyenne tous les 10 milliards jauzion
au campus de la haute énergie
j'ai besoin de produire beaucoup de
collisions et souvent donc au tennis et
au taux de collision c'est le cahier des
charges que doit respecter le lhc pour
permettre l'observation d'une pause on
dit ça en fait la machine de tous les
superlatifs
je veux faire ma liste alors on est à
100 mètres sous terre sous la frontière
franco-suisse que vous voyez ici nous ne
voulons pas meilleur emploi ticket blanc
croyez moi c'est là qu'entre en visite
au cern près de genève et vaud temps ci
refusant d anneau de 27km de
circonférence et voyagent à la vitesse
de 99,9
09/09 injonctions des bois pour son la
vitesse de la lumière des tests presque
à la vitesse de règne dans le sens
horaire pour les uns et dans le sens
contraire les autres pour fixer les
idées recettes correspond à un milliard
de kilomètres heure donc en gros pour
parcourir 25 km de là nous les protons
ont besoin d'un militant pour yan zi
millièmes de secondes à peine
alors ces produits pour que nous leur
commune pour chaque trajet particules au
cours de leurs trajectoires ont fait
régner dans les tubes dans lesquels ils
circulent un ultra vide la pression de
10 -13 atmosphère
c'est à dire plus frais raisonnables et
sa pression une cellule très vite et
règne dans les vingt cinq kilomètres
d'aullène en quelques points de la mort
on détourne légèrement les trajectoires
des bretons de la trajectoire quasi
circulaire pour les ferrandi en me
disant ça ça génère dans des volumes
extraordinaire d'un petit les énergie
colossale 13 teraelectron volts
dernièrement j'étais en confiance
s'était rallié au vote pour fixer les
intérêts et rigole correspond à
l'époustouflante énergie d'un moustique
en paroles et je crois que tout d'un
coup faisait perdre une répression
massive
oui mais au lhc ces énergies sont
concentrées dans les colonnes mille
milliards de fois plus de coups que le
volume et la mystique alors les projets
circulent par individuellement au
champagne et comme beaucoup de collision
a fait circuler dans le hcd mouillé et
chacun de ces milliers de paquets
contient plus de 150 milliards décrétons
pareil pour fixer les idées sans avant
première c'est à peu près le nombre des
toiles qu'il est vrai la collecte et
pour avoir beaucoup de questions ont
fait ce troisième ces matières tous les
25 milliards diane de ce monde alors
c'est gbagbo est repensé en fait son
plein de vide parce qu'elle prétend
c'est tout petit ça fait dix points 15 m
l'expression monde ou paca elle se
croisent s'interpénètrent j'ai fait le
break en deux paquets sont croisés
s'interpénètrent en fait seuls quelques
produits entrent en collision et des
photos qui arrive en sens opposé pour
augmenter les chances que ce que faisait
pas si on arrive juste à voir les toiles
collisions ont secoué ce les matières
premières ont dit toute leur dimension
concept qui atteignent alors quelque
chose de l'ordre de près car de chez
nous
la tête de l'ordre de 15 me promène et
ça ça permet qu'à chaque croisement de
paquets de protons et des dizaines de
collection prochaines années voilà
comment fais tu pour avoir beaucoup de
paysans en un an ce qu'ils pensent à
l'énergie pour maîtriser la trajectoire
des milliers de petites fautes on en
avait acheté le lhc cours il ya environ
juste je crois 9300 aimants qui sont de
toutes sortes les plus impressionnants
sont les 1200 ans
ti poule ils sont tombés la réforme est
possible qu'elle soit quasi circulaire
alors syndicaux il faut chaque heure 14
mètres de haut et de cinq à 35 2
ils sont en mots principalement pensé
d'un bobinage de finale on sera content
c'est du novillo titane et c'est
finalement qui font cette micromètres de
diamètre c'est tout petit sont ensablés
un truc pour faire des cas on peut faire
un calcul et il ya sept mille six cents
kilomètres de câbles dans le registre en
termes de filaments ça fait plus que
cinq allers-retours personnel en 1h02
finalement supraconducteurs et bien sûr
pour que ces cas soient vos origines
supraconducteurs ont fermé un froid
intense 1,9 degrés kelvin ça correspond
à nos charmants 270 degrés celsius et
cette température concerne 48 tonnes de
matériel voilà pour l'épreuve et lâcheté
et comment nous tiens beaucoup de
volition suivante et la haute énergie
alors leur dégoût vision des particules
instables sont faits qui se désintègre
ont d'autres particules qu'on a traqué
identifiées et mesurées pour pouvoir
remonter ce qui s'est passé lors de la
collision
alors pour détecter des particules qui
sont si petites orphelines physicien et
considère sans dimension
on utilise le principe suivant si on
veut pas voir une particule on peut voir
les traces qu'ils laissent sur leur
passage en interagissant avec la matière
de la même façon que on peut pas
réserver de l'invisible par définition
en revanche on pourra voir observer son
passage par exemple sur le sable wind
plage donc autour de chaque point de
religion du lhc est installé un
gigantesque détecteur vous avez atlas
d'un côté panneaux et cms de l'autre ces
détecteurs sont en quelque sorte des
caméras de 90 millions pixels qui
enregistre ce qui ce passe par de prison
et ce sont les visites et les
instruments de l'extrêmement d'abord
parce que elles sont synchronisées avec
le lhc
ça veut dire qu'elle prenne une photo
de solides mais ensuite elles sont très
complexes parce qu'elles sont
constituées de différents sous
détecteurs qui donnent des informations
utiles sur les particules de la ccms
sont comme des monstres de technologie
tapis ya 128 ans par leur calme
à grasse est un géant il est grand comme
un immeuble de dix étages ont infligé
sur le flanc avec ses 46 m de moins d'un
mètre et de diamètre et c'est assez
léger duvet scott cette jeune alors que
crs dont l'essai de drogba est presque
deux fois plus de titres et ses belles
12 8 500 tonnes alors les superlatifs ne
s'arrête pas là il concerne par exemple
si les moyens - il faut que des milliers
de physiciens étudiants ingénieurs et
techniciens travaillent qu'ensemble ils
viennent de dizaines de pays différents
et tout ça pour faire face
nous élèves de temps s'ils sont un peu
particulières il a fallu trente ans pour
concevoir imaginer à briquet le lhc les
vecteurs et ils vont être exploitées
pendant des dizaines d'années
et puis pour terminer je parlerai du
traitement des données qui compare à
huis clos si quand on sait que depuis
2009 démarrage de l acheter le
collisionneur a fini dessiné par
centaines de ce jour 2 milliards
opposition à étudier alors bien sûr la
recherche ça consiste à toujours dépassé
de mise au point de contraindre franchir
une je suis déjà à la façon dont pas
franchi les 80 pour la physique on a des
gars exacerbation du boson de higgs le
modèle standard au conseil
donc pour la physique des bas des
limites ça va être regardé ce qui se
passe ou de la vie monastique
on sait que tout l'univers n'est pas
décrit par me
là par exemple on ne sait pas qu'on ait
fait leur fameuse matière molle et pour
pouvoir faire ses futures recherches
la technologie aussi se projette dans le
futur alors en ce qui concerne le hajj
secte est d'équilibrer leurs comptes et
son énergie en revanche on peut
augmenter les taux de pollution par
exemple en compte en plus de produire
chaque paquet ou en densifiant squeeze
en évoquer davantage
ça c'est le projet ashrel la lâcheté qui
va prendre la suite du lhc aux alentours
de 2026 et avec ce projet là à chaque
croisement de paquets de protons
on devra observer plusieurs centaines de
collisions proton proton stéphanie
contre quelques dizaines d'emplois et
puis pour le futur l'a déjà en train
d'imaginer un nouveau collectionneurs
pourquoi pas une petite bête 200 km de
circonférence est forte
toujours au même endroit océane
tradionnelle et c'est beaucoup moins que
les traits les plus sympathiques de luxe
entre êtres humains c'est qu'il n'ya de
limites ni à notre soif de
grosse curiosité et on vend moins à
notre imagination
hormis
[Applaudissements]